All right. Let's now go to the the most important
thing that happened yesterday is something that
didn't happen. And what I mean by that is
the rioters were not able to prevent Joe
Biden's win from being confirmed. As I was saying
yesterday, as we watched with increased horror
during these live streams, almost six, seven
hours of stream yesterday as we watched
the capital breached and the Senate and House
chambers evacuated. And violence, violence,
violence, even including, you know, a woman died
yesterday, a kuhnen. Who believed yesterday was
going to be a day of reckoning of some kind,
a sort of pseudo religious belief almost
about what was going to take place, horrible
what we saw yesterday, but their goal was.
To prevent Joe Biden's win from being counted,
remember states already certified on December
14th, but from being counted and they were
unable to do that. And as I said yesterday,
the most important thing is safety.
Lock down the area, secure the building,
make sure nobody gets hurt. As few people as
possible get hurt. But we can't allow them to
actually delay the process. And indeed,
very late at night, early this morning,
Congress certified the election of President elect
Joe Biden. This was you know, there was almost a
backfire, which we will talk about in a moment.
But here is the moment where Mike Pence did that.
The votes for president of the
United States are as follows.
Joseph R. Biden Jr. of the state of Delaware
has received three hundred and six votes.
Donald Trump of the state of Florida has received
232 votes. The whole number of electors appointed
to vote for vice president of the United States
is 538. Within that whole number, a majority
is two hundred and seventy. The votes for vice
president of the United States are as follows.
Kamala Harris of the state of California has
received three hundred and six votes. Michael R.
Pence of the state of Indiana has received two
hundred and thirty two votes. The announcement
of the state of the vote by the president of the
Senate shall be deemed a sufficient declaration of
the person's elected president and vice president
of the United States, each for the term beginning
on the 20th of January, twenty twenty one.
Had they been able to delay this more than a few
hours, it would send a really bad signal. It would
embolden them to do this in the future. And again,
I want to mention only 52 people as of right now.
It may be more by the time you listen to this,
only 52 people have been arrested so far. We need
to make sure everybody who participated in this
and broke the law is arrested because otherwise
they will be emboldened to try this again.
But it didn't work. Joe Biden, everything
happened. No note that despite all of this,
everything happened on the day it was supposed
to happen. December 14th certifications,
January 6th bled into the 7th, but it was expected
to anyway, because remember, if there had been
objections from Republicans in six different
states, each generating two hours of debate,
this would have pushed into January 7th
anyway. Because of the riots, some Republicans
opted not to object in some of those states. So by
rioting, the rioters actually sped up, in a sense,
the process of just counting and accepting the Joe
Biden win. And that's really, really important.
Now, what this all means for the future of
the country, we just don't know. There's
really no parallel to this. I mean, we you know,
insurgents acting violently in the name of Trump
vandalize the capital. I from what I saw,
there has not been a breach of the Capitol
like this since early 19th century.
They objected without any evidence
that they could put forward to the acceptance
of Joe Biden's victory, claiming vaguely that
it was rigged with conflicting and unhinged
hypotheses. And this is essentially the worst.
I mean, listen, OK, they could have also brought
guns and started mowing people down. Right? Like,
we can all always imagine some worse
scenario. But when you talk about
what is the opposite of a peaceful transition
of power, what is the worse that this could
possibly get? What could be the possibly most
dire repercussions of Donald Trump's agitation?
It's essentially this. It's essentially, as
we saw it, it's disgusting. People need to
be held accountable, but importantly,
it's over again. Joe Biden won again,
another milestone that the Trumps were waiting
for to turn the election. It didn't happen.
Joe Biden's win has been confirmed,
and that's a very good thing.